euromaxx highlights and here's your host
laila ha Rock hello in a very warm
welcome to our highlights show here's
just a sample of what we've got in store
for you adrenaline rush speed flying is
a new extreme sport sci-fi sensation a
short film by Berlin student is an
internet hit and sweet success a German
candy maker hits the spot in Poland all
to our regular viewers it will come as
no surprise that here at euro max we
like to feature different extreme sports
but would you ski up a mountain and then
throw yourself into the air while
there's a name for it it's called speed
flying and it's all the rage a cross
between skydiving and skiing you need to
master paragliding and skiing of course
and then conquer your fear of heights
you wouldn't think it but it's going
mainstream more and more people with a
need for speed tackle the slopes and
take to new heights navigating cliffs
and snow at speeds of over a hundred
kilometers an hour equipped with just a
small fabric wing controlled by two
cords at times writers are in the air at
others on the ground Daniel coca from
Austria was one of the first people to
take up this extreme sport
it's fascinating every skier knows that
when you reach cliffs or rocks you're
tied to the ground and simply have to go
around them but with a parachute like
this you can simply ride down when the
terrain is impassable then I fly and
when I can ride I freeride things this
is skiing in 3d the Titans this is rishi
font ID speed flying originated in
France skiers used parachutes to get
from one piece to the next speed wings
have been on the market since 2006
kofler and his friends have developed
their own technology designed especially
for the Alps
weekly notable it's all about staying
close to the ground so you can really
feel them out and then fly up when you
need to you really feel the speed when
you're close to the ground and if you
don't have your chords under control
then you'll really feel the gravity and
you've got react very quickly mr.
Duckett alia outta style ina then v
atletico be the team's interactions of a
second to decide on life and death yes
natively again I get to some poor
telephone c'est comme la clé Middleton
to shine the speed Flyers test the
limits of both flyers and materials
Oh England we eventually tried speed
flying without skis but using such a
small wing to fly without skis is
unthinkable it only sheets of thing
speed flying is possible in the summer
too and some mountain climbers use the
speed wings for a quick descent back
down to the valley
it doesn't push that big on as soon as
people started taking off by running the
whole thing went crazy so many people
started doing it but there were a lot of
accidents especially in Switzerland
yesterday the manufacturers wanted to
come up with a solution basically you
need a bigger wing if you start on foot
without skis recently 16 square metre
wings came onto the market they're
easier and safer to use especially for
beginners the mini wings as they are
called are based on much bigger
paragliders Tonya Hobica is no expert
flyer but she wants to try out the many
wings warm our town let's see what it's
like with such a small piece of material
line anant Marshawn but after a few
steps she's up in the air the wing is
easy to control
and she lands perfectly
yeah super it's a great feeling vendee
that's one with does the little movement
turns the wing a lot can't explain blame
come you silly this it I should I put it
the filing of freedom you feel so free
and light look on license and yeah
kofler is also interested in the latest
development in the speed flying seen it
is hoping brought back the sport of fly
you can fly together now without lots of
instruments in massive straps my voice
what I like most is that people can fly
together nothing if you find a five or
ten people climb the mountain sit up on
the summit enjoy the view and then they
all fly down together your staff need
skate-a-thon clink to someone okay even
though Daniel kofler enjoys joining the
rest of the mini wing enthusiasts he's
still not giving up on his speed flying
thrills on the slopes
well let's leave behind those slopes and
enter the virtual world in fact with so
many people watching videos online these
days the internet is quickly becoming a
goldmine for movie producers one
aspiring young filmmaker from Berlin
made his own animated sci-fi short then
put it online it went viral so much so
that Caleb lake house keys film called
the attention of Hollywood executives
he's still a student in his early 20s
but his movie may soon be coming to a
theater near you a dark vision of the
future a robot holding an alien captive
the machines want to exterminate the
alien species that invented them against
all enemy forces eighty percent of our
military force this may look like a
Hollywood film but in fact it's the work
of Carla kofsky he studies digital film
design in Berlin it took him seven
months to make the short film he titled
ray when he uploaded a short excerpt to
the internet a Hollywood producer called
him up the very next day
cibc 50 cal at first I didn't believe it
I thought there'd be some response but I
didn't expect it this quickly or at this
level and so I really didn't believe it
until something actually appeared on
Hollywood Reporter and then 80,000
people washed by film on one day the
Hollywood producer is now his manager
and the film has been successful
continually reported on in the media Ray
has already racked up two million views
on the internet on car loudly coughs his
blog people post questions about the
film and the software he used to make it
the 22 year old believes details are
very important he spent several days
working on this aliens accouterments in
the finished film this equipment appears
in only one short scene normally only
well-funded studios go in for such
elaborate animation
hey chef asuka I try to animate very
realistically unlike Pixar and Disney
witch like to use exaggerated motions
more sweeping stylized motion see Stevie
see it sent when he kept a facility and
I tried to just have simple genuine
realistic animation because I want these
aliens to make a more human impression
the most not seen if you mention his
aqua babbling he made the short film as
a project at berlin's university of
media design he missed the course
deadline because the animation just took
too much time now the film's success has
led him to suspend his studies for a
year phacelia often high-power hype is
surely because he has already achieved
this quality at such a young age that
involved investing a lot of time and
sticking to his project and really
putting everything into it too and
sublime insistence all anger to for
biasing colorblock offski wants to use
his break from his studies to turn ray
into a feature film on a visit to Los
Angeles he already talked with several
Hollywood producers but the producers
are still skeptical they want to change
the whole story and bring humans into it
along with aliens and robots like offski
wants to remain independent and stick to
his own idea
the plan Piscotty the plan is not to
make a really expensive
hundred-million-dollar film but to stay
in a place where I still have the
freedom to try out something new with
the overall story this guns am da stead
and beyond that I am utterly convinced
that it's going to function even without
humans Oh what I mentioned who knows
maybe call a black house keys animated
alien world will soon be regarded as one
of the great science fiction films
now for those who love the wind in their
hair and their stomach in their throat
we might just have the outdoor activity
for you dangling hundreds of meters
above one of the most scenic landscapes
and whales I flying thrill-seekers can
get harnessed and soar over Welsh
mountains our reporter took to the air
this is not for the faint of heart
offering a 1750 metre long descent over
the phoniness lake in Wales this is
Europe's longest zipline
riders travel at about 100 kilometers
per hour and experience the feeling of
traveling at high speed with no brakes
brilliant best feeling ever she's
amazing as well yeah it's like you're
flying basically by doing what I
Superman kinda yeah what a rush what a
rush fantastic yeah I want to go again
Dylan Hughes lives near the snowdonia
national park he can barely wait to try
the zip line I've been looking forward
for about four months since they started
building the Sequoia I'm quite nervous
at the moment shaking and I'm expecting
a lot of adrenaline and excitement
he learns the art of flying by wire on
this shorter 500 meter course braking is
only possible when the rider sticks his
or her arms out heavier writers tend to
reach the end of the course faster
absolutely fantastic fantastic I'm gonna
go again the ride starts at the top of
the mountain instructor Sean Taylor
accompanies the participants to the
launch point
the quarry at its own hospital and the
hospital was Bell proposed the zip line
is located in an unused part of a quarry
that has been in operation since the mid
19th century setting up the course costs
600 thousand euros the concept is a
journey I think you've all seen
automatic this area is I don't think
there's anywhere in Europe that's got
what we've got here we've got the lake
we've got the culture with a quarry and
I think it's a magical place this is a
truly inclusive experience very special
experience but something that everyone
can do I never businesses will benefit
from this I'm very hopeful and we've
already seen people from all over the
world booking when you come home again
to wear heels baylor sings welsh folk
songs to keep up Dylan spirits before
the launch but he needn't worry the
courses safety has been analyzed and
tested by experts however high winds can
present a danger to riders at the end of
the course Taylor gives still infuse a
few tips before he starts
you need to breathe we have people go
down who do not breathe you can breathe
you're gonna reach speeds of 90 100
miles per hour and we make sure he's
still happy the person is still happy
because this is quite a dramatic thing
they're gonna be doing yeah I own half
here I just wanna call no yeah office
the winds seem to have picked up here
can you give me an accurate reading
please of wind speeds directions and the
last just please over the last two
minutes the wind conditions have changed
suddenly if it's blowing faster than 32
kilometers an hour he'll have to wait
hello it's 20 20 miles per hour
southeast and it's 15.3 over the last 10
minutes all clear it's a fast trip soon
after the start riders hit about 140
km/h often the slate outcroppings are
only a few meters below
but by the time the riders are over the
lake the trip becomes a bit calmer 55
seconds later it's all over in that
short time Dylan has made a descent of
400 vertical meters absolutely
brilliance brilliance you coming down
and you just rip of the slate and then I
you just go over the cliff line and it
just opens on all outside living room
and I'm tastic the place just opens up
beneath you and it feels like you just
fly you feel on top of the world a ride
on Europe's longest zip wire costs just
over 50 euros the owners are sure that
once riders have experienced the trip
they'll be back
well fashionistas on the hunt for
bargains usually prowl the internet for
that heart to find designer item auction
sites are a treasure trove for tech
savvy shoppers a global marketplace for
millions that are interested in buying
and selling everything one fashion
designer wants to tap into that market
and is setting up a virtual storefront
on ebay creations by dido maria
kretschmar with a whole new look forget
the sumptuous evening gowns this time
the german fashion designer has unveiled
a collection with a more leisurely look
20 outfits designed especially for a
short summer break and for a smaller
budget prices range from just 49 to 199
euros for original kretschmar creations
ticular to muffin me and salsa the
collection is a lesser known part of who
I am my designs are normally big and
glamorous but these are sporty light and
even cautious and for this dish but
that's part of my life too I think this
collection will appeal to a lot of women
misty fest malls greetings these are
many of my favorite clothes that can be
worn again and again and they'll keep
for years this form is Poisson
kretschmer has been showing his designs
in Berlin since 2005 normally he comes
here only during Fashion Week but this
time he's in town with 400 specially
invited guests for the unveiling of this
special collection it's to be sold
exclusively online I think they're very
wearable light and relaxed for the
summer which I hope will come this year
it's a great idea so far easterner
mishegoss it was like a mixture of let's
go to the tennis club and let's go to
central paid a demoniac fetch mojito
maria kretschmer is well known for his
very elegant feminine designs that's
true here too but of course you can tell
this collection is designed to appeal to
a wider audience
for years fashion bloggers Anya Stefan's
and Barrett Miller have observed a
growing trend of cooperation between
big-name fashion designers and
department store chains and internet
stories when I'm at the desk Ashwin
profeta it's something we've almost come
to expect we're already wondering who's
going to work next with hmmm or which
designer will be get to see more of I
think customers expect it now it makes
the big designers more approachable and
their work affordable I'm going to
highlight one day before the fashion
show the star designer was busy in his
showroom in Berlin finalizing the
outfits for each individual model 11
designs from the collection will go into
production each one will have 100 copies
the limited production ensures that the
clothes will not pose any competition
for his main fashion lines where the
designs cost around three times the
price
give our Vic teach the city glad
somebody did it was important to me not
to make any sacrifices in terms of
quality we have real silk super
Cottenham light jersey wool it's all
top-quality and made in Europe not
thrown together in some factory in China
awakening it's the same producers that I
work with normally I got them all on
board as I wanted everyone to have the
opportunity to buy something from me and
top-quality and for a super pricey
popeyes kretschmer first rose to fame
with his luxury evening gowns like these
shown at the last Berlin Fashion Week
betezh effi- my designs are very
feminine the cuts are very feminine this
here's perhaps very typical with the
crystal design very intricate in
beautiful colors timeless designs that
appeal to women but then also things
like this dress dresses that are
available in all sizes that show off the
figure and that are more simple Paul
this would push may the woman enjoys
food lives her life and is a bit more
rounded I actually find that more
attractive Clause but thin emaciated
look might be good on the catwalk
sometimes but not in everyday life back
at the Fashion Show there's another
unusual feature for the weekend
collection visitors are free to vote on
which 11 items they think should make up
the final collection a choice mostly
reserved for the big retailers
and all Photoshop when department stores
and shops place orders they decide what
gets produced so it's nice that it's the
customer in this case who determines
what will be sold and what won't capsule
do you think I have some favorites in
this collection and I'm so intrigued to
see if they'll make it it's a learning
experience maybe it'll be quite
different from what I expect but that's
what will go on to the market I think
that's great dido Maria kretschmer for
everyone or at least for those lucky
enough to get their hands on one of the
limited designs for the weekend
collection
well if you're ready to sink your teeth
into something sweet we know just a
place that hits the spot every time a
candy shop in Poland make streets the
old-school way on any given day you can
see the candy maker needing stretching
and sculpting colorful confections a
reporter went to get the scoop on the
Polish Willy Wonka all the colors of the
rainbow candies with flour for animal
motifs all made by hand by a german
candy man in poland yo man belgard store
is located in the historic center of
Gdansk here customers can watch the
sweets they made bail God used to be a
hairdresser in Germany but eight years
ago he moved to Gdansk and turned his
passion for candy into a career with
naman without thinking woman when you
sell handmade candies you really see
kids eyes light up in a way that they
don't with mass-produced sweets it's
really fun to see how the kids watch
when we work on figures or shapes the
basis for Florian Bell gongs confections
is liquid sugar heated to 160 degrees
Celsius several layers are woven
together until they form a giant sweet
it takes an hour to make about 10 kilos
worth of fruit flavored candies it's
painstaking work shaping and reshaping 8
kilos of sticky gooey sugar I stretch
out the sugar and that allows air in
that air changes the sugar in a few ways
one the sugar turns white which you can
see and that's because of the way light
breaks through it the second effect that
we see is the air makes the sugar taste
better the aroma has a better chance to
spread when you have air pockets
Julian bellegarde sweets come in a large
range of flavors and colors his products
are a hit with customers of all ages
belgaum has now opened his fourth shop
in Poland demonstrations and tastings
are part of his recipe for success it
takes four sites and skillful work to
create each motif and letter each piece
of candy gets a design the letter A in
the making each big strip of sugar is
turned into one letter Bernard istván
Blanco I'm an artist to trained
hairdresser I like to see the results of
my work it's nicer than working with
machines there are plenty of candy
manufacturers that work with machines
press a button and you get candy with us
you never know we work by hand so there
are surprises you want one letter and
get another or a strawberry candy
becomes a raspberry well that's how it
is simple [ __ ] off me look bellegarde
uses a technique dating back to the 17th
century in the year 2012 he started
selling his candies in Germany too they
were a big hit during the euro 2012
soccer championship and they still
attract a lot of German tourists here in
Gdansk I know we start with 160 degrees
Celsius but now I can break it black red
gold for Germany right this dish
ambitious customers can even have a go
at designing their own candies for Flo
Leon been gone to make for them a
personalized and very tasty souvenir
from Gdansk
and that wraps up our highlights show
thanks very much for being with us and
we hope you will join us again very soon
bye-bye from Berlin